[Musique]
bonsoir madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur travailleuses
travailleurs c'est à vous que je
m'adresse particulièrement ce soir la
question est la suivante comment vous
portez-vous je vais vous répondre tout
de suite je ne vais pas mal mais
rassurez vous un jour je ne manquerai
pas de mourir nous ne sommes pas les
mots ils ne sont pas les méchants même
s'il considère qu'ils sont les pots et
nous les méchants et bien je ne suis pas
disposé je vous le dis tout de suite à
subir le terrorisme intellectuel venue
d'une gauche que je considère comme
moralement et intellectuellement
décadent pourquoi vous voulez gouverner
avec eux mais précisément pour les
ramener à louches
ça va de soi j'ai pas la gauche la
france sipa la daurade la france voté
utile c'est voter pour un avenir
socialiste la france c'est tout à la
fois c'est tous les français le disent
mais chacun devra voter selon sa
conscience le bon choix est dicté par le
bon sens et à la j'assume pleinement la
responsabilité de cet échec et j'en tire
les conclusions en me retirant de la vie
politique la réforme oui la chienlit non
pas la pagaille dans les quartiers
chauds un lave ou de jeunes sauvageons
brûle la voiture de leurs voisins
j'essaie de me contrôler mais je suis
d'un tempérament plutôt vif l'extrême
droite
ce sont de fausses réponses à de vraies
questions mais je m'en souviendrai mon
cher monsieur je m'en souviendrai
mougeotte ce faux derche nu traitance
yeux de palper ok que l'objection règne
je vais faire courir moi tu vas le
rouquin et les deux coups vous démener
dans la fureur concentré elkabbach aux
mains moites de frousse je vous demande
de vous arrêter
je souhaite que chacun se reprennent
j'ai été très choquée je le répète par
l'expression qu'il a employés de safari
électorale tout le monde il ya intérêt
diddy safari dix chasseurs les chasseurs
ce sont les candidats
je considère que les françaises et des
français ne vont pas acheter un
président comme on achète un paquet de
lessive et 10 gibier et les gibiers ce
sont des électeurs que monsieur françois
mitterrand désigne ainsi et ceci est il
admissible dans cette campagne
j'ai dit que je voulais regarder la
france au fond des yeux mais je voudrais
aussi atteindre son coeur je sens mieux
que je ne laisse jamais senti battre
dans cette campagne le coeur de la
france et mon coeur bat avec ce coeur
qui bat
j'appelle tous les français quels qu'ils
soient où qu'ils soient à se réunir à la
force vive la république vive la france
[Musique]